[Music]
the key thing to know is we offer free
advice there are other agencies in the
area that do challenge money we don't we
are free independent impartial and we
are confidential
I take referrals I work predominantly
with tash it works both ways as well if
I've got clients have got housing issues
I can go straight attach it and we can
arrange things like discretionary
housing payments we've had one recent
success where we had a very very
vulnerable client who was fairly
suicidal that had maintenance problems
with the property so - caught the head
of maintenance involved we will met out
round the clients house and agreed and
maintenance schedule I then went on to
sort out her welfare benefits for you
see a lot of information in national and
local media about joined-up services
there is no such thing as a joined up
service it is all down to what made
Suffolk District Council and the
partners that they bring in to make
happen don't put your head in the sand
don't avoid us don't avoid the council
we can help we're here to help we have
clients up do not open the letters
unless areum with one of our advisers so
more referrals keep us in the loop and
we will do everything we can to help
you
[Music]